COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
a Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some music masters
with their connection quota.
Will we hit the high notes?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Meister was adopting
the latest and greatest
in serverless technology.
And it recently moved
some of their systems
from Compute Engine
to Cloud Functions.
Sadly, one challenge popped
up as the new function
started to eclipse
their connection quota.
But wait a minute--
connection quota?
See, most likely,
your GCF calls will
be doing a lot of
external RPC calls,
querying APIs, fetching
proxy resources, et cetera,
et cetera.
Each outbound request
is a connection.
And there is a quota
involved with it.
So if each one of your
functions is doing 10 RPC calls,
and you're running
a million instances,
quota might get in your way.
Thankfully, GCF has
a little feature
that allows you to reuse
connections between invocations
of a Cloud Function.
If you're fetching
from the same host,
you don't have to pay the extra
overhead of the new connection
since it's already opened.
For example, code like this
was being used by Meister
to fetch an asset from
one of their databases.
Although this code
is pretty standard,
the HTTP request
has no persistence,
which means that it
performs a new connection
on every function invocation.
We can fix this and maintain
persistent connections
by using a custom HTTP agent
with the Keep Alive option.
After running a small test, the
Cloud Function's API quota page
in the Cloud console
shows a huge improvement
between the two code
paths-- and also has
the side effect of decreasing
DNS resolves, which,
by the way, is also something
you have to provision quota
for.
Now, in my opinion, one of the
strongest things about GCF is
it's out-of-the-box support and
helper libraries to the rest
of Google Cloud.
However, because
those APIs generally
make RPC calls through
socket connections,
we can run into the same
problem with connection quota.
For example, when using
the Cloud Pub/Sub API,
their code was using one
connection and two DNS
queries per invocation.
However, by moving the Pub/Sub
variable to a global state
and declaring it cons, we can
remove unnecessary connections
and DNS queries,
resharing the connection.
With these simple
changes, Meister
was able to get an 8x reduction
in connection and DNS usage.
To learn more about our
changes, check out the article
linked in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas
content-- because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]